leur quotidien n'a pas été bouleversée
que ce deuxième confinement c'est jeune
tennisman peuvent s'entraîner tous les
jours au comité de tennis dei mille de
feucherolles ils ont obtenu une
autorisation ministérielle pour pouvoir
continuer leurs activités
donc en fait il ya des listes de haut
niveau et sportive jeunes au niveau et
je figure dessus en iste l'espoir du
coup j'ai droit de m'entraîner donc je
m'entraîne ici la semaine avec des
partenaires qui sont parlées sur une
liste au niveau et le week end je peux
pas aller dans mon club parce que c'est
fermé
c'est vrai que c'est quand même une
chance qu est-ce que c'est notre année
aujourd'hui alors que je sais qu'il ya
beaucoup de monde qui aimeraient être à
ma place ici à feucherolles ils sont une
dizaine à s'entraîner du matin au soir
un vrai plus par rapport au premier
confinement selon les encadrants pendant
le premier confinement du mois de mars
en fait les enfants ont continué à faire
du travail physique chez eux
mais malgré tout ils ont quand même
beaucoup perdu et on a mis du temps à
retrouver un niveau correct donc la
halle avantage c'est que les
entraînements se poursuivent donc il ya
moins de pertes c'est tennisman ne sont
pas les seuls à s'entraîner dans les
yvelines ils sont des centaines de
sportifs à avoir obtenu cette dérogation
des catégories espoir aux élites on
retrouve notamment des athlètes
susceptibles de partir aux jo de tokyo
l'été prochain comme le versaillais
thomas baruch médaillé de bronze en
aviron en 2016 à rio
si on n'avait pas pu aller dehors
s'entraîner sur l'eau on aurait quand
même pu faire ce qu'on a fait au
printemps dernier
continuer le travail physique sa part
exhorté le trail physiologique mais
voilà un sport n'y a pas que de la
physiologie et aussi beaucoup de
technique beaucoup de précision et de
sensations et quand il n'est pas sur
l'eau mais on les a pas cette dérogation
s'appliquera jusqu'à la fin du
confinement au minimum jusqu'au 1er
décembre